c'est un nouveau coup dur pour l'open de
france de golf déjà annulé en 2020 le
rendez-vous 2021 est officiellement
reportée
il ne se disputera pas à huit clos du 6
au 9 mai sur les greens saint quentinois
la décision fait suite aux nouvelles
annonces gouvernementales concernant la
propagation de kobe de 19 en france on
regarde cette décision est la décision
la plus sûre c'est vrai que
effectivement voilà je pense que tout a
été envisagé cadres et on a beaucoup
travaillé de façon très proche avec
l'european tour avec la préfecture avec
les différents services et la décision
qui a été prise c'est la décision la la
la roue à dire la safe au total cette
104e édition et attire entre 850 et 900
personnes venus de 25 pays différents
une difficulté dans le contexte
sanitaire actuelle pour les
organisateurs c'est compliqué trek
actuellement bayrac d'aider des notions
de 850 personnes pour lui faire manger
d'accord donc faire manger 850 personnes
en respectant les contraintes sanitaires
de deux mètres carrés par personne
c'est un problème qu'il faut résoudre le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines attend
désormais une nouvelle date dans le
calendrier du tour européen au rendez
vous pourrait être décalée à la fin de
l'été l'événement pourrait cette fois-ci
accueillir un public